golde megawhatts and tough talk on
immigration Tommy got these freeloading
immigrants off that backs and built that
wall no this isn't a Donald Trump wet
dream it's Spike Lee's scathing
portrayal of war race and injustice in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into two five Bloods to examine how this
film isn't really about a quest for gold
but about something far greater but
before we begin make sure to LIKE and
subscribe with that bail on because here
we go it's no coincidence that de5 blood
starts and ends with archival footage of
two of the most important figures in
african-american history Muhammad Ali on
the left and dr. Martin Luther King jr.
on the right notice the juxtaposition of
having a literal fighter on the left and
a peacemaker on the right this duality
is seen through the characters in the
film most notably Paul the fighter and
Norman the peacemaker
Muhammad Ali questions why his fellow
brothers are being sent to the slaughter
to fight an enemy that has never harmed
them to fight for a country that lynches
in shoots at his people not consoles
will let me go shoot my brother some
darker people some hungry people in the
mud of America
this is echoed by Hanoi Hannah a
real-life radio personality and
propagandist during the Vietnam War who
gave speeches in English directed
towards the American military she talks
about how African Americans at the time
made up 11% of the population yet were
32% of the troops while Muhammad Ali
shared this bleak outlook he's
juxtaposed with Martin Luther King who
has a message of hope America never was
America to me and yet I swear this oath
America will be this is a quote from
african-american poet Langston Hughes
his poem let America be America again
which sounds a lot like make America
great again which I'll get to in a bit
however in Hughes's poem the title is
used mockingly for african-americans the
history of America has been one of
slavery and oppression why would anyone
want to revert back to that the end of
this poem however is one of
hope that America will one day be that
idealized vision of freedom equality and
opportunity we're not there yet but we
can dream that we one day will the
introduction is laden with examples of
both military and police oppression the
history of America through the lens of
Spike Lee is one of subjugation violence
and injustice both internally and abroad
seeing these images do we want to make
America great again and for whom are we
making America great for it's easy to be
pessimistic about the world given this
introduction but as we'll find out as
the film unfolds Lee leans into hope
just like dr. King the film may begin
with pessimism but ends with hope in
modern-day Vietnam we meet our four
protagonists Paul Otis Eddie and Melvin
they've teamed up to search for a stash
of gold they buried almost 50 years ago
this gold was originally meant for the
lahu people a gift from the Americans
for signing with them during the war but
the Bloods buried it hoping one day to
come back and use the money to help
their own 1619 this speech is given by
Norman the fifth member of the five
Bloods and their leader
the Bloods aren't just looking for the
gold but also Norman's body so that he
may be brought home and given a proper
burial of all the men Paul had the
closest connection to Norman which is
odd since Paul goes against almost
everything Norman stands for when the
bloods here that dr. King has been
assassinated Paul calls her blood Norman
however invokes King saying that they
need to control their rage and be
peaceful when Norman says the gold
should be used for the betterment of
their people
Paul leader says the money will be spent
on himself that goal should go towards
Black Liberation you do for self Norman
is seen as this saint-like figure in one
scene even sitting on a makeshift throne
made out of palm branches in Christian
theology palm branches symbolized
victory triumph and peace all things
Norman represents this is juxtaposed
with
who symbolizes greed violence and rage
Paul's story is one of tragedy he served
three tours in Vietnam killed his best
friend by friendly fire a secret he
keeps hidden that Fester's inside of him
he also watched as his wife died giving
birth to his son David and has a
complicated and dysfunctional
relationship with him David is also a
foil to his father
whereas Paul is uneducated David went to
college to become a teacher David wanted
to become the opposite of what his
father was in a sub conscious effort to
lash out at his father who never loved
him Hall even chooses abandoning his son
who is just shot in order to leave in
the jungle on his own with his share of
the gold Paul also wears a make America
great again hat completely oblivious to
the effect it would have on the people
there a country which lost millions of
lives due to American military
intervention during the war but this hat
becomes a metaphor for greed throughout
the film in fact the only characters who
ever wear the hat are all deeply flawed
greedy and violent individuals we have
Paul and the European gold smuggler day
rush fun fact the French translation of
day rush is rocks the same thing that
comes out of otis 'as matt pack when
they trick him at the end of the film
it's no coincidence this had a symbolic
of greed considering Spike Lee's vocal
criticism of US President Donald Trump
who adopted the slogan make America
great again for his 2016 presidential
campaign it's pretty clear in the film
what spike thinks of the current US
president I guess you're too busy
watching reality TV or electing a
reality TV clown for a president so
charges claims accusations allegations
in a
oceans connected to the clansmen an oval
office Forli manga greed and trump go
hand in hand
and Trump himself has been very vocal
about how greed has been one of the
driving forces of his life because my
whole life I've been greedy greedy
greedy I've scraped all the money I
could get I'm so greedy but now I want
to be greedy for the United States I
want to grab all that money
Paul's Ark however isn't without some
form of redemption after bitten by a
snake Paul confronts the ghost of Norman
a ghost he doesn't want to see away men
please he doesn't want to confront the
thing that has caused him so much pain
all these years the thing that's given
him nightmares every night by keeping
the secret that he killed Norman buried
inside him he's let it fester making the
pain inside him lash out to those he
loves including his son it's here that
Norman tells Paul what he's needed to
learn all these years that it wasn't his
fault and that Norman forgives him
Norman's forgiveness is in line with his
almost christ-like character he even
says that he died for Paul just like
Christ died for our sins I know you
while Paul and Norman are
philosophically at two ends of the
spectrum
Otis is caught in the middle swaying
back and forth between these two men as
if caught in a tide near the end of the
film Otis is shot by des Ross who throws
the make America great again hat onto
his body and when des rushes Shawn we
get this madness laughter and madness
this whole situation is so out of hand
Otis can't help but laugh and I can't
help but think this is Spike Lee
commentating on the state of America
today the manga hat on full display over
the body of a dying black man well in
Vietnam
Otis fell in love with a prostitute
named Thien and unbeknownst to him
fathered a daughter these children of
American soldiers became known as Bui
doy or children of the dust they were
mocked and looked down in Vietnamese
Society for being the sons and daughters
of sex workers and looking like the
enemy no one knows the exact number of
half a mare
can half-asian children were born during
the war but the estimates are in the
tens of thousands part of Otis's journey
is cultivating the relationship with his
daughter who at the end of the film he
embraces finally happy and the film ends
largely on a positive note as the Bloods
are able to get the money for their gold
and put it to good use
we see here Melvin's wife [ __ ] and
their son she's received a check for two
million dollars at the beginning of the
film Melvin tells the Bloods that she
wants to move out of the neighborhood
ever since a group of thugs moved in so
this money will absolutely help for that
we also see her holding a Purple Heart
but we aren't sure if that was
previously earned or somehow
posthumously awarded for his valiant
show of bravery taking a grenade for his
fellow men at a black lives matter
headquarters one of the organizers says
they just received a check for two
million dollars this check is from Eddie
one of the few voices who said the money
should go back to the people
in a similar vein Hedy Simon and seppo
share has gone towards the fight against
landmines Eddie's life has been devoted
to helping those affected by war she
feels somewhat responsible for what has
happened in countries like Vietnam
because her ancestors were complicit in
the exploitation of the Vietnamese
people the French had colonized Vietnam
and her family made a fortune off the
various rubber plantations and Bryce
farms which utilized Vietnamese labour
this is her way of paying back then even
gets his share which judging by the
posters in the back of his agency looks
to have gone towards his business we
also get a short epilogue featuring
Norman's two sisters as his body is
brought back to US soil this is followed
by David at a school where he teaches
African American history the board
behind him is filled with various black
historical figures but this whole
epilogue is narrated by Paul in his
final redemptive moment
this is him reciting his letter to David
a letter he wrote before the main
offense of the film and only to be read
upon his death in it he details how the
demons of his past haunted him and how
that pain was taken out on his son he
acknowledges how he made David feel like
he wasn't loved how he failed him as a
father and to let him know it wasn't his
son's fault there are small interesting
details here like the empty bottle of
Walker and the pictures of his family in
the background this was a deeply
troubled man but one who deep down loved
his family even if he rarely showed it
you best believe the film ends with the
words of Langston Hughes recited by dr.
King with that hope of a better America
but as the final text scroll indicates
we are reminded we are still far from it
dr. King a man of peace was shot for
standing up for what he believed in and
if there's anything recent events
surrounding George Floyd and the BLM
protests have shown us is that things
are still far from that idealized
American dream of freedom and equality
the real treasure of defied Bloods
ultimately had nothing to do with gold
it's forming these new relationships
love and forgiveness until we as a
society learn this too we still have a
long way to go thanks for watching
everyone if you liked this video please
make sure to LIKE and subscribe I'm
always coming out with new videos you
can also follow me on twitter at things
story whitey